[Musique]
bonsoir
chadwick moore merci de répondre à nos
questions sur arte france avec un joe
biden place donc à une nouvelle
politique sanitaire aux etats-unis une
politique qui contraste avec celle de
donald trump sections différentes
administrations baden a produit est 100
millions de vaccins mais 5 millions de
vaccins ce n'est pas 100 millions de
vaccins ils veulent salir de vaccins en
cinq jours mais il faut deux des secours
à une formation complète doses à ce jour
trois millions de personnes ont reçu les
deux doses de pentaxim et l'animation
stration trump peuplé de vaccinations
par jour
l'administration aux jeunes non cash
beaucoup d'informations que
l'administration précédente n'aurait pas
pu être critiqué très fortement parler
mais les médias sont beaucoup plus
prudents avec joe biden cette
administration problème sur
l'administration précédente
mais le fêter c'est le projet de joe
biden maintenant et la lustration
précédente atteignait 100 millions un
million de vaccinations par jour
vous l'avez dire 100 millions de vaccins
distribués dans les 100 premiers jours
du mandat de joe biden les précommandes
de sérum commandé par donald trump qui
sont loin d'être fabriqués donc du coup
à vous entendre c'est difficilement
réalisable ce serait donc un excès de
confiance c'est cela combien de vaccins
disque aux administrations bâle ii et la
lustration bailleul et refuse de le dire
donc on d'administration beit-el la
l'administration trump en disant qu'il
ne leur ont pas donné toutes les
informations nécessaires
alors que l'année sera sion 2-3
respecter ses objectifs une
administration baden signé plus de
trente décret présidentiel cela passe
par la présence des femmes transgenres
dans le sport jusqu'à l'annulation de
projets de pâques lines et air canada
président pris feu dans tout ceci mais 4
à 5 des faits présence lors de leur
premier joueur à au pouvoir mais n'était
pas elle se concentre sur des sujets
tels que justement les personnes
transgenres tant l'appétit sme et se
désintéressent de la vaccination mais ne
s'agit pas que des vaccins il faut
également organiser la logistique avec
les centres de vaccination les
personnels tout cela je parlais des
centres de vaccination la célèbre
enseigne de grande surface
wal mart propose des centres de
vaccination dans des supermarchés on
évoque également une aide logistique
d'amazon
comment est ce que la population
américaine voit c'est main tendue de la
part de géant
industriels ou du web les vaccins de la
grippe par exemple peut être reçus dans
des centres super martiaux il ya des
pharmacies dans le magasin walmart
donc cela n'a rien dit ni oui c'est une
bonne chose si ces revendeurs veulent
aider mais pour le public américain
selon marianne2 le nouveau effectivement
amazon pourrait t'aider à la logistique
ne soit pas encore certain de tellement
de tout cela n'aurait rien
d'extraordinaire pour les américains et
les revendeurs américains
il ya eu un cas de variants brésilien
qui a été détectée on parle évidemment
du variant sud africain du variant du
coup on a un virus britannique et
maintenant on évoque un variant
californien les vaccins justement alors
qu'on parle de cette politique de
vaccination voulue par joe biden est-ce
qu'ils seraient toujours efficaces face
à ces nouvelles souches qu'est ce qui se
dit aux états unis au sujet du vaccin
protège au moins contre les variants
brésilien élévation britannique les
ailes aux mutations saleh pas inattendu
et le virus se montrent et en fait il
s'agit presque d'effrayer la population
lorsqu'on parle d' immunité collective
eh bien il faut savoir que cela ne se
fasse forcément que tout le monde doit
être vacciné
la réalité c'est qu'une majorité des
américains ont sans doute plus déjà le
virus sans même le savoir
la vaste majorité des gens qu'il
contracte le coronavirus n'ont quasiment
pas de symptômes
donc beaucoup de personnes sont déjà
entre guillemets vacciner car ils ont
les jeunes en contact avec le virus et
l'idée de vouloir vacciner
la population avec ces nouveaux variants
qui apparaissent c'est une autre chose
il semble pour le moment en tout cas que
ces vaccins restent efficaces ces
vaccins bien sûr produits en un temps
record qui pourrait peut-être avoir des
effets secondaires on n'est pas sûr en
tout cas voilà ce que les entreprises 10
pour le moment on l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure je change de sujet je ne parle
pas de vaccin on a parlé de la politique
intérieure de joe biden qui travaille
également sur la politique extérieure il
ya eu un échange téléphonique tout à
l'heure entre le 46e président des états
unis et vladimir poutine
les deux hommes qui sont entendus sur le
traité mutare teint de désarmement
nucléaire bilatérale
comment est-ce qu'il faudra voir dans
les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines les prochains mois la relation
entre washington et moscou
mais la mitsu viatique ce qui lui
apparaît sous l'administration entrante
une déposition une hostilité entre la
russie et les etats unis la russie
serait encore le grand méchant de la
guerre froide
mais en fait la situation était plus
compliquée que cela l'administration
obama n'était pas très lucide envers la
russie tient sur l'administration de
l'administration trump les médias ont
prétendu que continuent dans la lancée
de l'administration obama alors sans
doute qu'il aura effectivement les
accords sur l'armement nucléaire
il ya eu des frictions entre obama et
poutine bien sûr mais cela montre je
pense que la façon dont les médias
représentent les situations s'était
notamment
mais sous le mandat trump change en
fonction de la situation donc on ne
parle pas de copinage entre entre baden
et poutine il n'y a plus de théorie du
complot selon laquelle joe biden pour
renverser la démocratie aux états unis
et c'est tout simplement parce qu' il
aime bien le jeu bail de ne pouvoir
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
j'ajoute moore depuis les états unis je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
politique